told you Morty he still got it
you sons of [ __ ] what's the job
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Rick and Morty season 4
episode 3 video there were all kinds of
Easter eggs
it was mostly a send-up of heist movie
tropes and adventure treasure hunting
movie tropes so we'll break it down if
you're new to the channel I'm doing
videos for all the episodes this season
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we're also doing a weekly Rick and Morty
merch giveaway obviously careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet we'll do top 10 WTF and Easter eggs
as we go along starting with number 10
the title one crew over the cuckoo's
Morty is obviously a reference to One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest with Jack
Nicholson but also the fact that Rick's
whole bit in the episode flew right over
Morty's head it was all about Rick
getting Morty to stop working on his
script and his plan was successful
number nine they opened with a big Star
Trek reference where Morty is trying to
free climb up a mountain base while Rick
is following him in a hover chair eating
an Arby's sandwich which I believe is
integration because they try to make
sure that you definitely see the Arby's
wrapper when it flies towards the camera
at the beginning of Star Trek by Kirk
also falls right off of the mountain and
Spock has to save him with the hover
boots then they turned it into a bit of
an Indiana Jones Raiders of the Lost Ark
parody with them trying to get a gem
from an alien tomb with a bunch of
elaborate traps that are all from
Raiders the Lost Ark all the traps that
they walk through wearing the anti booby
suits were from Raiders Rick uses the
entire episode starting with these
scenes to call out tropes of movies like
this either treasure hunting or mostly
heist movies in more than anything the
Ocean's eleven movies but there were a
couple of other different heist movies
that they were parroting your overall
enjoyment of the episode I think is
mostly predicated on having seen a lot
of heist movies or at least seeing the
Ocean's eleven movies so some of the
bits might not have landed quite as well
for you if you don't care about heist
movies or if you've never seen any of
them so for a number of reasons I don't
think this episode was quite as strong
as episode 1 and not quite as deep and
impactful as episode 2 there were also a
lot of Indiana Jones Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull references during this -
you could also call this dungeon built
by advanced aliens but made with really
old timey traps a bit of a reference
to Kingdom of the Crystal school but
there's also an actual Crystal Skull
that they use during the heist off later
in the episode everyone probably spotted
the Boulder Raiders reference with it
trying to chase them down but the anti
boobies who's just bouncing it off and
then obviously Indiana Jones's hate of
snakes total waste of snakes which is
also a meta callback to get schwifty
because Rick keeps snakes hidden up his
pants legs number eight Rick breaks the
fourth wall again when they approached
the tomb when he says Morty should take
a beat to acknowledge the sacred
atmosphere to give their cynical
grave-robbing a hint of a reverence
which is another heist movie trope but
they find out that Rick's nemesis
Michael Knightly beat him to it
leaving an origami horse which is one of
many Ocean's Twelve references to the
jackal character who was their nemesis
trying to one-up them the whole time
Michael Knightly also kind of reminded
me of Michael Knight from Knight Rider
but I don't know if that was an
intentional reference with that name he
was voiced by Justin Theroux who you may
have recognized but he was actually the
second celebrity guest cameo during the
episode you probably recognized the
first one because when the dead body
rises from the tomb as they leave its
Claudia Black who's back for the first
time I think since season 1 when she
played the leader of the females but she
also breaks the fourth wall when she
calls out the ridiculous idea that who
builds a tomb that collapses on the
person that is there to protect 7 they
go to high scon to get the gem from his
nemesis but the convention itself is
mostly a parody of comic-con in real
life with Rick getting super frustrated
with badge registration and then not
being able to get into Hall H anyone who
has ever tried to get into comic-con or
even just by a regular badge or try to
get into Hall H probably feels seen it's
exactly like this it's super frustrating
the lines are super long is really crazy
we get our third celebrity guest cameo
in the woman at this desk it's Pamela
add lon
back again she did her Bobby Hill voice
from king of the hill in last week's
episode as the son of the fly mob boss
that Rick was threatening to kill Morty
references Catherine alpha Jones which
is an Easter Egg for Catherine
zeta-jones who was in two of the Ocean's
eleven sequels in zeta is the opposite
end of the Greek alphabet from alpha
they do the bid in the trailer about
Morty putting on too much pointment and
transforming into a huge winged creature
that Rick has to hunt down it's implied
that it's still our Morty though or at
least the same
- morty from the beginning of the
episode even though when rick was
warning morty he made it sound like he'd
have to hunt him down and kill him if he
put too much on everyone grab another
voucher for one free replacement morty
but number six the first crew they do
their Ocean's eleven montages rick is
the George Clooney character goes around
assembling his crew just so that he can
get past the door of Hall H all those
weird transitions are right out of
Ocean's eleven the big guy is a
reference to Livingston who was
performing stand-up in a comedy club
when the George Clooney character finds
him the woman is a reference to the
robot hands at the beginning of ghost in
the shell' with her confusing ass hands
trunculus is a reference to the brothers
from Ocean's eleven running a racecar
track in the race itself is a bit of a
reference to Wacky Races this guy looks
like he's right out of Mad Max fury road
this guy driving the banana car who
himself is a piece of fruit wearing a
banana also feels kind of like a Beverly
Hills Cop banana in the tailpipe joke
but trunculus an actual vampire voiced
by Ryan Ridley it's the second time that
he's done a vampire character he was
also the vampire in the post-credits
scenes from tiny Rick number five they
do their lab coat ripoff Doctor Strange
joke obviously dr. Strange's cloak of
levitation has a mind of its own and it
strangles people when Doctor Strange
asks it to so Rick does the same thing
with his lab coat but he's breaking the
fourth wall when he says rip off the
movie dr. strange the bit with the heist
contest is a reference to the contest
that they had during Ocean's Twelve with
The Jackal obviously the Crystal Skull
is a reference to the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull then Rick proceeds to call
out all the tired heist movie tropes he
hates with a bunch of competing montages
and twists with in twists throughout the
montage when they're doing all these
different reveals and bits the guy
that's secretly another guy all of these
are based on the real bits that they did
during Ocean's Twelve number four the
double-cross in the second crew so Rick
gets double-crossed by hyster Tron which
is another trope of heist movies but
then assembles a totally random crew to
fight the algorithm that he used to
program heist a Tron and apparently the
Greek gods are real in the Rick and
Morty multiverse because he goes to get
the Greek god Hephaestus from one
reality mr. poopy butthole comes back
and apparently he's been a college
professor for some time now Rick trains
his students to attack him which they
later call
at the end of the episode wait a minute
weren't you in a hurry how did you spend
all that time training those people we
get our next big celebrity guest cameo
in Elon Musk playing Elon tusk and they
just do a tusk bit with all of regular
Elon Musk stuff like he runs Tuscola
instead of Tesla all the jokes about
them talking and moving around his
office and being sorry about wasting
time it's just a joke about Elon Musk's
efficiency he's really big on being
efficient he works seven days a week so
he hates wasting time ventriloquist bits
during the episode with the arrows that
turn other people into ventriloquism
dummies Rick burns David Lynch in his
movies when referencing the inspiration
for his seemingly random plan he also
wants to play a lot of Minecraft
but we've known for previous episodes
that Rick is a big fan of Minecraft the
last time he referenced it during season
3 he made an autism joke implying that
he himself might have autism because he
likes Minecraft but during this episode
he also calls Morty out for having
Asperger's so maybe he does
maybe that's Rick just saying that the
episode goes way over the top when the
heist robot starts doing bits from
Ocean's Twelve with the spy camera and
the giant pizza box when they all start
executing their random plans Morty
starts spasming out on the ground just
like he did at the end of the pilot
episode after shoving the mega seed up
his butt that number 3 Rick vs. hyster
Tron
final battle the bit of their final
battle went on a little too long but
it's just more of Rick calling out heist
movie tropes over and over bits within
bits within bits trying to overload high
stat Ron to me number 2 the Netflix
jokes were just a little bit funnier
just because they were a little more
true to life
Morty almost successfully sells his
heist movie to Netflix but then realizes
because of all the things they've been
through that it's a really tired genre
he kind of hates heist movies now and he
doesn't want to have anything to do with
it so he just kind of leaves it aside
even though the Netflix executives are
ready to buy the pitch in the room
that's mostly a joke on the idea that
Netflix will buy any idea that you throw
at them they have the final reveal that
Rick planted this whole way just so that
Morty would get disillusioned and
stopped working on his script which is a
callback to the new family power dynamic
they introduced in episode 1 with beth
ordering rick not to directly mess with
Morty's hopes and dreams which he
dozen in number one the post-credits
scene was a bit of a call back to mr.
poopy buttholes class and him calling
out Rick for succumbing to all the
tropes that he himself had been calling
out the entire episode like I said
overall your enjoyment of this episode
probably just depends on how much you
like heist movies and how many of these
movies that they're making fun of you've
actually seen if there's any Easter eggs
you spotted in the episode that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments I'm working on a
trailer video for the next episode that
should post pretty soon but just a heads
up there is no new episode of Rick and
Morty next week episode 4 won't be for
two more weeks because of the
Thanksgiving holiday so no worries I'll
just remind people when I post my
trailer video congratulations Nick
Leonardi you're the giveaway winner from
my last Rick and Morty video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details
everyone click here for my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 2 video and click
here for my new Mandalorian episode 3
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]